Hey,
what's going on?
What's going on?
It's bill bird.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
February 13th,
2017 what's going on?
How?
Why?
Yeah.
Huh?
Y'All,
how you doing over there?
Why is it,
why is Friday the 13th on lucky and Monday the 13th all that's just fucking
fuck.
You know who was a pussy?
You came up with that one.
You think Monday the 13th fuck you're unlucky 13 and it's Monday and I got five
fucking days in front of me.
I have to work Friday 13 who gives a shit?
You stub your toe a couple of times and next thing you know you're at the Tgi
Fridays,
right?
You down their eyeball and one of the ladies,
yeah,
you come up to her,
you tell her you like her striped shirt.
Start bitching about the horrible day you had.
You know,
and she's a woman,
so she'll listen to it.
She'll kick into that motherly instinct unless she already has kids and then she
doesn't have time for it,
you know?
Then she looks at,
just says,
listen,
I made sucking your Dick Guy.
Right?
So you get the fuck out of here and then you move on to something yoga.
It's not how it goes.
Why?
What is so fucking unlucky?
You know what?
I didn't even know it was going to.
I gotta look this up now.
Why is Friday the 13th unlucky?
Hang on his stomach.
Hit pause for a second.
All right,
before I can,
I just looked it up.
I didn't read any.
I just got,
I just got to the Google thing where they got whatever it is on the first page.
All right.
Whose kid know with the Internet,
whatever the fact is,
the fact is whatever you look up within the first two fucking clicks on the
first page becomes the truth.
That's it.
Okay,
so that's what the fuck I'm looking at.
You know if the right answer to any question is fucking beyond what you have to
scroll down on the first page of any subject on a of the Internet,
it's,
it's over.
No one's ever going to know the truth because it,
who?
Who the fuck ever goes to page 14
okay?
Not even journalists do that.
They don't give a shit.
I'm all right.
I'm going to say it either has to do with,
uh,
it's gotta be religious.
It's gotta be religious.
Jesus did something.
He always had bad Friday's,
didn't he?
No.
He had a good Friday.
Good.
Today's Good Friday.
What happened on Good Friday?
Then the little rock roll back and he came walking out,
you know,
like one of those fucking movies where they thought they killed the guy and he
didn't.
And then he comes back step,
not like Tom Sawyer fucking creep hanging out at his own funeral.
I was done with that kid once he did.
That shows that these kids are fucking Weirdo.
I'm all right.
Friday the 13th.
Why is it unlucky and other facts about the worst day in the calendar?
In the calendar,
not on the calendar.
We're in it.
We're not in it.
We're not on it.
All right.
Finally,
13th considered by many as one of the unluckiest days of the year is almost here
again.
This is from January,
2017.
Uh Oh shit.
January 13th well fuck.
Nothing happened to us.
If he's still alive.
If you're worried about what's in storable Bababa,
blah,
blah.
What the fuck in 2000 here's some of the fun facts.
When is the next Friday?
The 13th and why?
Stupid.
All right,
baby.
We'll orange origins.
All right.
Course.
It always goes back to the Bible.
Oh,
Jesus.
His Dad's mad.
Dad's coming home.
He's not in a good fucking mood.
He had a bad week,
you know?
Of course it's the kid's fault.
Stupid cunt.
He tried to build everything in six fucking days.
Typical do it yourself job.
Why didn't you farm it out to someone in know what the fuck they were doing?
Built the thing up to code yet.
Dope fucking stick in a steel beam in the middle of a fucking wood wall.
Yeah.
Everything above it is supported better.
What about below it?
Debt.
The fuck did this music come from?
All right,
let's read with this music on in the background.
Superstition about this day is not to have,
I can't do this.
Start to have come about.
All right.
That's enough of that.
During the Middle Ages in many have biblical origin.
Some historians have claimed it was the day on which eve bit the apple from the
tree of knowledge.
Jesus Christ.
Hmm.
Hold it just scared the shit out of me.
Nia.
The lovely near everybody.
Oh,
with my beautiful daughter.
Two lovely ladies.
What's going on?
Uh,
I thought you were done.
Sorry.
No,
I was watching the videos that people sent me this week.
What's going on?
Are you going to drop her off?
No,
I can't do the podcast the way I talk.
That's why I was in here with the door closed.
It's a pocket door,
by the way.
If you wonder why,
just squeak.
Like we live in a haunted house.
No,
I just found another,
I just saw another place that uh,
I want to show you that maybe you wanted to order from.
Yeah,
just order me something remotely healthy.
Okay.
Something to stave off the calories.
I consume an alcohol.
Okay.
Would you like some sort of like a,
a bowl with rice and Tofu and that sorta thing?
I hate Tofu.
It's gotta be a real dead animal and vegetables.
Okay.
So you want,
you want meat so I shouldn't order from a vegan place then I like I vegan.
As long as there's none of that Tofu.
I don't understand what that stuff is.
That's like the type of shit that they seal capsule with some Tofu.
Yeah.
So liquid doesn't be good.
It's not good for you.
Tell us who is not good for you.
No.
Are you sure you're thinking until four or you when a TOEFL doesn't come from a
tree,
does it?
There's no tofu trees.
I thought Tofu was made from soybeans.
Yeah,
but isn't so bad for you.
No.
Always.
I have no idea.
Let me get your phone for you.
I don't know.
Just if you're going to order from a Vegan place,
just get me vegetables.
Shit that I,
I,
you know,
I know what I know what it is.
I Dunno what Tofu was.
It's like fucking allergy or something.
Okay.
All right.
Shuffles Nia.
Do you know why Friday the 13th is unlucky?
I Dunno either.
I've been reading about it here.
The new,
and then they started to say that Eve fucking maybe bit the apple.
Oh,
they were in paradise.
There was no calendar.
What do they have to worry about?
Snow bills.
I,
you have to go to work.
Right.
You know,
what did they do in,
in,
in fucking eat off shit.
It Monday.
Same Shit.
Different Day.
It's fucking paradise.
No salad though.
I was an honor to stand.
Why?
If it was paradise,
why they had a fucking snake in there trying to fuck everything up.
The devil.
Yeah.
But that's on God
to separate.
They're not to say if God made everything else made.
He also made the comment of all cons.
Did he not?
Oh No.
But the devil was an Angela like cast out.
So the devil was basically a bad hire.
Yes.
It came back and tried to take his company down.
All right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let me finish reading this.
And the New Testament,
um,
I love,
or they blame the woman.
Like that's why everything's all fucked up.
I mean,
without a doubt,
if you told a broad,
did not go over there and eat the fucking apple,
she's going to be intrigued.
Yeah.
You know,
like a guy wouldn't.
Whatever you did,
that's still classic thing.
Like it's substitute teaching.
Whatever you do,
don't laugh.
Next person who labs gets to tension,
that's it.
You're done.
You fucking squeeze in your nose doing that fucking little kid laugh.
That's it.
Next thing you know,
you're missing a week of research,
uh,
recess.
That's why you got all these fed fucking kids.
The regular teacher takes the day off to substitute.
Teacher creates the tension though.
The one skinny kid starts laughing and then he's done.
He's eating that fucking food down in the cafeteria that's got all the
preservatives in it.
Do you know if you fucking kill somebody younger and nobody figures it out,
you're not in the clear for a good 40 years.
That's how long the digging people up from 12 years ago in there.
Then it's like they took a fucking nap.
Okay.
Hey,
I'll tell you these people,
they're full of preservatives,
you know?
All right,
and the New Testament.
Okay.
There were 13 people present for Jesus.
Jesus,
his last supper
on Maundy Thursday.
Okay.
Monty M Maun dys at some other fucking day of the week.
They used to have.
Yeah.
Do you mean the new testament that wasn't in the Old Testament.
Oh,
wait a minute.
We fucked up dot.
There was 12.
There's 13 the day before crisis.
Crucifixion on Good Friday.
Oh,
Good Friday.
See when Audi had a couple of bears,
he had a good fucking time.
And the next thing you know,
you've got the old right there,
Fred.
All right.
More bad luck on Friday,
October 13th,
13.
Oh seven,
Philip the fourth of France.
Shouldn't be,
uh,
Felipe Lik cat.
Okay.
Um,
arrested hundreds of,
of the knights Templar.
Well,
what the full,
what would have,
what did they do then is novel Da Vinci Code.
Dan Brown sites,
the 14th century execution.
Oh,
who gives a fuck?
You know what I mean?
You know something,
it's just,
it's just all bullshit.
That's what it is.
You always know it was,
I'm trying to think of any bad's ever happened.
Me On the 13th,
but I pay up Fadiman you get bad luck today.
Fucking old ladies keeping that shit going.
That's what it is.
Oh by the way,
I'm really good friend of mine and one of the fucking best comedians I've ever
seen.
Nick Depaulo the Great Nick Depaulo.
He has a new standup special,
a new one hour standup special that's debuting a this Thursday,
February 16th at 8:00 PM 8:00 PM on Seeso TV called inflammatory.
Um,
I don't get to watch them as much since I'm out here.
Uh,
but he,
he is somebody,
last time I worked with them was a comics come home once again.
Legendary set and um,
that's it.
He's just one of those fucking guys.
He's just,
he's the guy.
Um,
he's the shit and he's got a new special on Cecil.
Check it out.
Thursday,
Friday,
February 16th at 8:00 PM,
it's called inflammatory.
And he also used to host a show with a,
I'm already lang and now he's doing his own podcast,
uh,
to subscribe to this podcast.
You can go to connect pal.
C O n n e c t pal Dotcom.
Slash.
Nick.
Um,
alright.
There we go.
So do you know what,
you know what the Fuck I did today?
You know what my dumb ass did.
Today's I getting on the elliptical,
which was a good thing.
All right.
I took my life insurance,
fucking test,
skate a problem,
hitting my vein.
He goes,
you're going to bruise a little bit.
You should see me.
I look like a,
I don't look like I've been doing smack.
I just looked like somebody just pinched my fucking inside of my elbow really
fucking hard.
Um,
anyway,
so I did all that.
Ugh.
What a shit show that was fucking guy's sitting there going,
oh dear.
Do you drink it all right and like he's got his back to my bar,
which I told you his murderer's row,
the bottles I have there,
I told you right now I'd put it up against the 27 Yankees to 96 bowls.
Let's go some underrated teams.
The 83 76 hours,
somehow lost in history,
but how fucking great day.
We're right.
The 86 Celtics see 85 Lakers
the fuck in 2016 New England patriots.
I'm the 98 Yankees.
That was a great team for the fucking free agent.
Their weight.
I mean,
speaking of which though that the red sox and doing that this year,
it's a good year to get the package,
no matter what,
you're going to be entertained.
Do you get to watch like a fucking $900 million team?
Shit,
the bed or just,
you know,
there is no Santa Claus.
We're buying it one or the other.
Either way it's going to be dramatic.
Um,
so anyways,
I got a such a funny question.
I make drinks tea.
I don't fucking know.
Do I have a pocket protector?
I don't count them.
I like,
you know,
they,
they always think,
you know what's funny?
They fucking say having a glass of wine with your meal is actually good for you.
You know what I mean?
So I mean,
I don't,
I don't understand that.
Okay.
Do you smoke?
Yeah,
Lou a little bit.
Fucking lying your ass off.
Um,
okay.
Oh Jesus,
I will.
Can you imagine if he,
if you magic anybody,
even if fucking people who work there,
if you answer to any of those questions,
fucking honestly,
you know what I mean?
Alright.
Uh,
Bruins.
And I probably shouldn't be talking about this.
Who gives a shit?
There's a comedy,
podcasts.
These are all jokes.
Everybody.
Um,
this is what I did today.
My fucking dumb ass did today.
So,
you know,
I'm going to be the person,
a presenter at the writer's guild.
No,
the,
yeah,
the writers guild awards thing.
Right.
And,
uh,
so let's say it's a black tie thing and I'm like,
oh fuck,
I gotta get a fucking Tuxedo.
So I call it,
by the time I call up,
it's too late to get one.
So Nia,
Google some pictures and everybody seems like relaxed.
Like they're just wearing suits with a black tie.
So I say,
fuck it.
I'll wear one of my suits.
I pull out a suit,
I get the shirt,
we do the whole fucking thing.
I got it to go and all that.
So today I'm dressing up.
Okay.
You know,
I'm hanging with my daughter,
I'm putting my time in,
you know,
cause I'm gonna be gone for three,
four hours and a knee is going to be handling it by herself and I'm going to go
out and go do this,
this fucking Hollywood thing,
right.
And A,
and I'm sitting there and I know,
you know the red carpet and everything's between three and four and I'm like,
I can't,
I don't know when the fuck the cars coming to pick me up.
I'm all dressed up,
ready to go,
you know,
two o'clock two oh five to 10 to 15 I'm texting people,
hey,
once this car coming to get me to 25 I walk outside,
I'm looking around,
I don't see anybody
just sitting there and it finally dawns on me.
I'm like,
wait a minute.
And I just looked up the date of the fucking award show.
It's next Sunday.
That's hilarious.
You know the funny thing about it is Nia get mad at me.
Yeah.
Why did you write things down?
Don't give to him.
It's not,
I didn't miss it.
I just was a little early and now I know,
you know.
Okay.
I know that you know,
I know what I'm going to,
where I'm actually way ahead of the game cause I cause I fucked up.
What do you want from me?
Um,
anyway,
speaking of,
uh,
this is something I got to let you guys know about.
Um,
the,
uh,
the Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit,
the fifth annual Patrice O'neal comedy event,
uh,
benefit.
Uh,
we're actually going to be releasing some,
um,
some tickets,
some a high tickets I guess you say some really good seats and we're going to be
doing that,
uh,
Monday today.
If you're listening to it on Monday.
Um,
Jesus Christ with the fucking open under the door there.
What is ridiculous?
How am I trashing you?
Got Mad at you because you can make them,
I can make him come in here,
come in and come in and don't yell,
don't yell.
You've got the kid there.
What?
It's absolutely absurd for you to not know when things are anymore.
It's like you're a grown ass man and he's got all dressed to go to the,
why is it always grown ass?
Why can't you say you're a grown up?
I can say whatever I want to say and I'm choosing to say that you're a grown ass
man who can't seem to write anything and is that because you're a strong woman
to the point where you're going to get all dressed up and be like,
well,
what am I going to wear?
There's nothing the other,
and then you come downstairs five minutes later like,
well,
it's next week with you.
You need to get it together.
It's not cute.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's like the first thing I've screwed up like that a long time.
I have a bunch of events in my phone right in the calendar section we're getting
when things are,
you're always getting the dates wrong and it's frustrating.
It's just annoying.
Yeah.
All right,
but how am I doing as a dad?
What does that have to do with anything you're doing amazingly as it all right.
We'll stop acting like I'm in some shooting heroin in an alley acting like a
shooting heroin in an alley,
but you just need,
I just don't understand why you can't ever get your schedules to,
hey,
you're always getting the dates wrong.
Like,
oh,
it's tomorrow.
Not Today.
It's next week.
Not this week.
Like I don't,
I don't get it.
Yeah,
I'm busy and I don't have an assistant.
You will.
You should get an assistant.
I don't want another person to talk to.
I've been telling you when you get an assistant for like three years now because
of this very reason.
Yeah.
You want to hear all this shit I did this week that I made totally got there on
time.
You don't.
Okay.
You know why?
Because that would prove my point if I was a baseball and share.
What is your point exactly at 99% of Shit I get there on time.
99% 98
no and you did
get mad at me.
I'm not.
I said,
well then what's the problem?
Why did you have to draw a radically open her squeaky pocket door to come in
here and cert yourself on the podcast?
All right.
Are you done?
Are you kicking me out now?
Are you almost done?
No,
I've just started.
Well,
people send me a note.
I'm 17 minutes in.
Oh,
Jesus.
And I came up here to watch the Grammy's,
but I can't turn the TV on now.
Right?
It'll go watch the grammys.
Okay.
I'm going to,
is it going to be a bunch of people like right new versus about how Trump's the
most evil thing ever.
There's some check that showed up on the red carpet weighing it's sparkly dress,
make America great again,
and then Trump on the back of it.
I don't know who she is,
but everyone's already like,
what?
Oh my gosh.
She's like,
just for somebody
to show up at a Hollywood event like that and addressed it says like,
you know it's approach.
Trump is pretty,
it's pretty paint by numbers shock,
I guess.
Do you think she'll get some free press out of that?
I think she will.
Yeah.
Was she wearing Madonna's Baret?
No,
she was not.
I'm going to a protest.
What should I wear?
Uh,
no.
It's just when you're pro Trump approach Trump dress is what I'm saying.
I know.
I know because that other shit is played out.
You're acting like the sky is falling,
so now they're going to go the other direction.
Yeah,
I know,
but I feel like that's not going to be like good press for her.
You know what I mean?
Hey,
totes.
Any,
any press is good.
Press tell this dirty time works.
Yeah,
I guess so.
Okay.
Well you could just put out a good album,
right?
And not rely on your stupid clothes.
Yeah.
If you put out a good albums,
you can keep your clothes on.
You don't have to say who you voted for.
B can just go up there and no,
except your shiny thick.
That's true.
All right.
I'm going to take the baby.
Okay.
Bye.
Okay,
bye.
Anyways.
Hi everybody.
I'm glad.
Yes.
All right.
If you pull the door lower,
it doesn't squeak as much.
See,
there you go.
See that?
You almost did it.
You can watch the Grammy's.
Nick,
go ahead.
Okay.
Um,
anyways,
oh,
by the way,
I'm going to fuck this up.
The two fucking best channels right now in my,
in my,
uh,
not humble opinion.
Hey,
people say in my humble opinion,
like you're a humble person.
You're not,
you're injecting your fucking ideas most likely into a conversation that you
just overheard.
Or is that just me in my opinion?
I don't know when the humble came about,
you know,
hey,
I bought,
who am I?
Who am I?
Who are you?
You're the fucking guy that is,
is,
you know,
holding court right now with you with your opinions.
It's not the fucking humble about this.
You shining a spotlight on yourself.
You know,
I'm actually in a good mood too.
Hang on a second.
Let me,
let me fucking find this stuff.
There's too fucking channels out there.
Viceland is the shit.
I already told you about that.
And now what's his face?
Uh,
puffy.
She has a new network.
Puffy.
You can't,
okay.
Puffy is network.
They said net worth revolt.
It's another great fucking channel.
Both of those channels remind me of the early days of MTV.
The early days of MTV was somewhere between,
um,
obviously regular television and then just basic cable fucking lunatics,
which I really miss.
I remember I used to watch this guy.
Uh
Huh Damon.
Zach's talks about this a long time ago in the [inaudible] and Anthony Show.
He used to pretend he was running for office.
Damon Zach's,
there it is.
There it is.
This guy was a fucking superstar.
I think it was channel eight
areas.
I love this fucking guy.
Oh this is,
this isn't going to translate.
Well d a m.
He used to do this thing where you pretend that he was running for office,
this crazy makeup on and just saying all this fucked up shit.
And me and Bobby Kelly,
we'll live in together when stone.
So,
but we would just watch that guy
like late night after we did our spots,
just ordered Chinese food and would just sit there watching the guy laughing our
asses off and fucking getting freaked out.
MMM.
I Dunno.
But the early days of MTV was like that and I haven't seen,
you know,
network television or basic cable be like that in a long time.
And I got to tell you those two fucking channels.
MMM.
Just great.
A bunch of random shit in their,
uh,
original shows.
MMM.
I don't know.
Puffy is more like,
I just sat there watching it.
It was that guy a what the fuck's his name?
Not Mike Jones guys.
Really killer Mike Killer Mike.
And I guess the guy he wraps with his white,
I don't know anything about,
but they fucking just filmed them.
They just sat around talking about their albums.
One Guy Smoking weed,
he has like a fucking coughing fit for like 30 seconds.
They don't even edit it out
out of habit.
Just sitting there and I'm like two hours into this thing going,
how the fuck am I still watching this?
But it was way more interesting than a lot of,
I don't know.
I like it.
Check it out if he,
if he,
if feel like it,
you like it,
whatever.
What are you going to do?
Um,
anyways.
All right,
let's,
uh,
let's talk about the world of sports as I always do,
as I eventually do,
as I always make my way back to the old bread and circus here.
Um,
Bruce Cassidy,
new coach of the Boston Bruins,
former player,
came up with the Blackhawks and like the eighties,
and unfortunately I'd like three or four knee injuries.
This is all I know about the guy.
And then,
um,
he paid his fucking dues as a coach coming up.
My favorite stopped that he had on the way up,
he coached for the Jacksonville Lizard Kinks,
which,
you know,
I'm throwing and I'm throwing my vote and that's one of the best,
uh,
okay.
It's one of the best fucking names from minor league tema the Lizard kinks.
It's a reference to the doors.
They got a bunch of reptiles in Florida and fucking Jim Morrison got arrested in
Florida for allegedly taking his dick out.
Also known in some circles as you lizard
and who doesn't want to be a king?
You know,
if you've got the Sacramento Kings,
you got the La kings and he got the Jacksonville Lizard kinks.
Um,
anyways,
he's undefeated so far,
you know,
granted,
we were playing their best hockey I felt to this season when I,
when he took over.
But uh,
this is the new guy,
you know,
I got to a support there.
Um,
what's his face posture?
Knock with the fucking,
uh,
with the game winner
against the Vancouver Canucks after he made it very sketchy pass in the first
period.
He makes it up fucking unbelievable.
K down the fucking left side,
slammed on the brakes,
just like I do it,
pick up hockey except he actually stopped rather than continuing into the boards
and hurting himself.
Um,
and then fucking little,
whatever the fuck he did,
he put it in.
It was fantastic.
Oh,
it was tremendous.
Um,
but I got to tell you guys about the greatest sporting event I think I've been
to since I went to the,
uh,
New England patriots first Los Angeles Rams when we won our first super bowl
and all I can tell you about Duke at Cameron indoor arena.
It's like
how loud the crowd was with Vinod Terry kicked that field goal.
It was that loud,
the whole fucking game.
I've never been to anything like it.
And we sat in the low,
he was sitting in center court.
I thought we're going to be behind the bench.
Sorry about that.
We would send a court,
um,
not on the student's side across from them in the lower area.
And Dude,
I'll tell you,
there's no fucking way to get out of there.
There's no way to go to the bathroom.
There's no way to fucking,
there's nobody coming around a concessions.
You are fucked.
You are in there.
And that is it.
Old School.
Fucking barn.
Um,
okay.
You went in,
it's so small.
I guess it holds like 9,000 people,
but you have,
you felt like you were in there with like 200 people and we came in and it was
already,
uh,
they were already shooting around before the game and uh,
we finally got to our seats.
Like you just don't think that you seats are even going to be there because
everybody is so jammed in.
And um,
we didn't sit down for the whole fucking game.
I guess I started sitting down during timeouts cause I'm old and I got to tell
you,
I've never,
I've never seen an atmosphere like that ever.
This beats everything.
I've been to the NCAA.
Uh,
the championship game was in the fucking Georgia dome.
So I mean that's a shitty place to watch a basketball game.
Even if people go nuts,
it just floats up to the top of the,
the,
the dom and you don't even hear it.
Um,
okay.
I've just,
I,
I don't even know what,
I didn't know where to begin.
And then it was an unbelievable game,
just back and forth,
back and forth when it looked like you was going to pull away,
Duke would come back.
Then it looked like Duke was going to have the game on ice and then you wouldn't
see,
would come back.
Somebody hit a three,
someone else would hit a fucking three was unbelievable.
And I was very impressed with both teams.
I like that kid on UNC number 44.
He doesn't rattle.
He doesn't fucking act like he changed the game of basketball when he hits a
shot he gave a fuck about was winning.
He had some big three pointer and then they immediately called timeout and
rather than thumping his own chest and acting like he's in Braveheart,
he came back to the bench high fiber.
Do you see he was pissed because they just said just let up an easy bucket
before he hit his three.
And um,
I don't know.
I don't know shit about anything,
but if I was a scout I would pay attention to that just as much as somebody's
actually doing great things out on the court.
And um,
it was insane.
Dude.
Fucking coach k coming out.
I just,
I'm reminded me of when I,
when I went to the king's game,
when they wrapped it up one time to win a Stanley Cup and I saw them bring the
Stanley Cup out.
It was like that except it could walk around talking.
So I want to thank,
uh,
I want to thank my call at the comedy zone in Charlotte for two awesome shows.
And thank you so much for getting us in touch with a person that hooked us up
with the tickets a me versus the bar,
Nick.
We're all sitting there going,
I think that might've been the greatest sporting event I went to.
Obviously seeing the Patriots win the super bowl was bigger,
but um,
the level of excitement.
I,
I just never been,
never been to anything like that.
And uh,
if you ever get a fucking chance,
um,
that is definitely one worth stub.
Hobbing
MMM.
Oh,
the college give fucking the students were crazy and they had all these funny
chance and I'm sure everybody's going to say all they stole this from you.
They stole this from this guy and blah,
blah,
blah.
I don't fucking know.
But it was making me laugh.
You don't want anyone to introduce in the UNC players,
I'll just use my name.
They just say,
yeah,
play in fucking point guide number fucking zero bill burr.
And then the whole student section just goes,
hi bill,
you suck.
And they just did it through the whole thing.
It was childish.
It was fucking hilarious.
They started chanting.
I couldn't tell what they were chanting,
and then I gradually figured it out.
It was crazy towel guy.
I was like,
crazy.
What the fuck are they saying?
Crazy?
What?
And people start turning around looking at us,
and then I realized,
I look and be honest,
and we look up and all of a sudden this fucking old guy gets up,
starts whipping this towel around his head,
this old fucking lunatic.
I'm like,
oh,
I guess that's,
I guess that's the crazy towel guy,
right?
So it's going back and forth,
back and forth,
all these crazy chance.
You let your whole team down all of this shit.
The next scene,
oh,
it's like halftime.
We're sitting there going like,
dude,
what the fuck was that?
That was 20 minutes of basketball.
They felt like a minute.
My ears were ringing.
Like I'd gone to a concert and there's still another half to play.
Then all of a sudden this Asian lady comes out,
this Asian lady coming out on like a fucking three story unicycle and she's
doing that act where you,
you're fucking,
you flip the saucer Rania head.
Okay.
Which I had seen before.
I've seen the act done before.
I never seen it live,
but was fucking hilarious.
Versie and bar nick had never seen that,
that saying I wasn't blown away.
I was definitely blown away.
So she,
she goes to like flip it on.
I had no,
first of all,
you know when you stop on a Unicycle,
he can't just stop.
You've got to do that front,
back,
front,
back to,
and now she's doing that with one foot on the fucking pedal.
She's got a God damn soup bowl on one of our,
the end of our feet on her toes.
You under your feet.
A lot of people notice your toes,
right?
So everybody's sitting there,
She fucking flips it.
It does like a triple Lindy and lands on the top of her head and everybody,
everybody's just like,
ah,
Shit.
Right.
So then she fucking what?
The thing's still on her fucking head.
A little soup kitchen.
A Cup,
dare,
right.
She rides down to another,
the other corner of the basketball court.
Now she puts two down.
Now.
First he starts going,
no way,
no fucking way.
No fuck away air right there,
Fred.
It fucking lands whole crowd.
Oh Shit.
Then she goes to do three,
so she's got one upright.
The others upside down the other is upright,
just going like right up her fucking Shin and she fucking landed that in forsee
stood up.
You ever see what black people go to church and when they call it catching the
holy ghost,
that's what looked like happened to Paul Versey.
Everybody was sitting down first.
He stood up and applauded.
I'm fucking dying laughing.
She goes to four balls.
Everybody's like,
no shit.
Four balls go on the air.
Land right on the head.
One,
two,
three,
four,
whole crop,
right?
Then she goes down,
her closing bit,
not one,
not two,
not three or four.
She puts five fucking soup bowls.
It's all the way up to her knee.
Okay.
Oh,
I forgot to tell you this.
This guy is like flipping the balls.
So he flipped one tour and he fucking threw a too short and she dropped it and I
was going,
I fucking just jinxed her.
He just fucked with their rhythm.
It's like calling a timeout to ice the kicker.
So she's got five flips him up in the fucking air.
One,
two,
three,
four and the fifth one bounced off my head.
Everybody's like,
ah,
ah Jeez.
There is no Santa Claus,
right?
You know what she said?
She said,
fuck that.
Set them up again.
Right?
Teaching these kids,
these fucking millennials or whatever the fuck you call these kids nowadays,
these kids who grew up with knee pads,
elbow pads and helmets,
when they rode bicycles,
they had play dates.
They,
they weren't left alone in the company of adults that no one really knew who
they were.
These,
these kids were sheltered.
They don't know how to make a comeback.
These kids get drunk.
They Call Uber,
right?
Everything's just set up for,
so they don't know how to fucking pull themselves off the mat,
you know?
Well,
let me tell you something.
This lady on this one fucking tired bicycle,
she showed them how cause she said,
hey,
fuck head,
I don't give a shit that you throw me five more.
She set him up again,
right.
Flip them in the air.
Landed all five fucking place goes nuts.
Just as loud as the God damned.
Almost as loud as the fucking game.
There was no break.
There was no break in the excitement.
That fucking edge will look and go,
what the fuck did we just say?
An outcomes coach,
k fucking Duke and UNC and it gets loud again.
More and more singing,
more fucking screaming
came all the way down.
Duke finally put the game away with like a fucking minute left with a couple of
foul shots.
And,
uh,
I would just sat there in the last few seconds when I knew that Duke was going
to win.
And I just looked at,
looked around,
looked at everything I could look at,
try to make as enough mental pictures as I could to take it in,
because I knew I was just like,
I don't know if I'll ever get back to,
to seeing one of these again.
But,
um,
I dunno if that didn't sell you,
I'm fucking Gig.
You got to do it.
That is a dude.
Fuck Madison Square Garden.
It's a mecca.
Fuck that place.
You can go down there and see the fucking ice.
Capades save your money.
Go on stub hub.
All right.
Go on stub hub and,
and just get yourself some tickets and go there.
You will not be disappointed and you got to go.
Well,
coachK is still there.
Who by the way,
okay.
I believe tomorrow the 13th is his 70th birthday.
How great does that guy look?
Okay.
Fucking guy looks like he's like maybe a year younger,
two years older than me.
I don't know.
Um,
who would thought with,
uh,
with a,
a job that's stressful.
You could still look that good,
you know?
Um,
anyways,
let me read a little bit of advertising.
Here we go.
Oh,
dollar shave club,
Everybody Dollar Shave Club.
All right.
You know something,
there's no reason to use cheap disposable rate.
Do you use it a cheap disposable razor or pay a ridiculously high price for some
gimmicky thing that's got a laser pointer was 17 blades.
Make this choice and join dollar shave club before dollar shave club.
It was either save money and get a painful shave from a disposable,
like the ones that give away for free at the gym,
which felt like shaving with a piece of fucking glass or he paid a fortune for
the latest gimmicky shave breakthrough that you didn't need that had like a
fucking laser chin detector or 17 blades or whatever.
Dollar Shave Club is the best of both worlds.
Worlds a premium shade and a disposable price.
Get a close,
smooth shave every time.
And,
uh,
you can't,
you can't beat the convenience or the price of the club if you haven't tried
dollar shave club yet,
you're missing out.
It's an amazing shape.
God,
they write so much fucking copy.
There's no smarter choice.
And right now they're giving away a one month trial for only a,
any of their razors for only a dollar was free shipping.
And after that,
it's just a few bucks a month.
There's no long term commitment,
no hidden fees.
You can cancel whenever the fuck you want.
Get your $1 trial it dollar shave club.com/bird that's dollar shave
club.com/burr oh
in some of our faith,
one of my favorites here.
Look who's back.
It's all zip.
Are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
You son of a bitch.
Posting your jobs in one place isn't enough to find high quality candidates.
You might as well walk down the street and say,
hey buddy,
buddy,
do you want a job?
No jogging.
Sorry.
Right?
You might as well do it that way.
That make any sense?
Probably didn't.
I'm just saying,
you know,
people use this shit.
You're going to be behind the eight ball.
This is why I stick to the copy.
Posting your job and once one place isn't enough to find quality candidates.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job on all the top job sites and now you can with Zip
[inaudible] dot com you can post your job to 200 plus job sites including social
media like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click.
Find candidates in any city or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified candidates roll in to Ziprecruiter's.
Easy to use interface,
no juggling emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates rate them.
Oh,
look at her and Ted.
We'll give her a shot and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why zip?
It's been used by fortune 100 companies and thousands of small and medium sized
businesses right now.
My listeners can post a job on ZipRecruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com/bird that's ziprecruiter.com/bar one more time.
Try It for free and go to a zip.
Bam.
ruda.com/burr MVMT watches,
also known as movement,
watches.
Pronounced movement.
Yeah.
Was founded on the belief that style shouldn't break the bank with the 1 million
watches sold the customers in 160 countries around the fucking world.
Movement watches has solidified itself as one of the fastest growing watch
companies.
And let me tell you,
the owners of this company,
while they're personalize,
have suffered broken marriages,
broken dreams,
but God dammit,
they're getting you these fucking watches.
Um,
the company started by two broke college kids.
They didn't have any money.
And then somehow they started a company.
I've never understood that detail,
uh,
wanted to wear stylish watches,
but they couldn't afford it.
So they started their own watch company.
This definitely sounds like an ivy league.
Thank you know,
when I didn't have a fucking watch and I didn't have any money,
I just didn't wear a watch.
I didn't start a fucking watch company.
These Kennedy's how was,
okay,
how is this like how you started build a fall?
Shut up movement.
Watches start at $95 a department store at a department store,
you're looking at four to 500 bucks,
move and watches,
okay?
Basically,
they got a great watch.
It's not in a department store,
so they can cut out all his fucking money and all these.
They start at 95 bucks.
The great people won't know that there's a piece of shit.
You know?
It's not a piece of shit,
but they won't know that.
It's not like I'm fucking,
you know,
how do we get out of this?
It's a nice watch.
All right?
But it doesn't cost a lot of money,
okay?
Over 1 million,
watch yourself.
You don't over 160 countries,
get 50% off today with free shipping was free returns by going to movement.
watches.com/bar this watch has a really clean design.
Seriously.
All right?
You'll get a bunch of compliments whenever you put it on,
okay?
Even if it's sitting on,
oh my God,
is that,
that's a really nice quality watch.
Don't touch it.
Now's the time to step up the game.
Go to movement,
watches.com/burb join the movement.
Oh mercifully,
this is the last one.
Oh,
stamps.com and everybody,
you know,
I use stamps.com whenever I send out my posters of my,
uh,
my sports bras,
whatever the fuck up selling at the end of shows to whore myself out.
You know,
when I was like,
you know what,
I,
I'm going to go out of here and make a little bit of extra cash,
you know,
shake some hands whenever he 15 is going to fucking feel like they just got out
of a sauna.
Postage rates have gone up again,
that means trips to the post is a post office or even an even bigger hassle.
Man,
it's so crowded,
but thanks to stamps.com you don't have to worry about that.
Just use stamps.com to automatically calculate and print the correct amount of
postage for every letter or package.
You said stamps.com brings you all the service of the post office right to your
fingertips.
We'll even send you a digital scale.
Automatically calculate the exact post is they do everything but send a fucking
robot and then I'd do it for you.
stamps.com we'll even help you decide
the best class of mail based on your needs.
They give you postage discount.
She can't get it to post office,
including 3 cents off air.
Be First Class stamp.
Right now,
use my code burr for this special offer.
Four week trial includes postage and a digital scale.
Why would the post office do that?
3 cents off going to their business.
They,
they must have a cut a stamps.com I have no idea.
Four week trial includes a postage includes postage and a digital scale scale.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone,
whatsapp the homepage and type in birth that stamps.com enter burr and sign up
today with stamps.com you'll never have to go to the God damn post office again.
All right,
and with that,
you know there's this thing,
it's just really not responding the way it used to.
Is it time for a new laptop?
All right.
Do we have anything else?
Hey,
what is all this attacking on fake news lately?
I don't understand it.
Why is the government getting so mad at fake news?
It's so fucking hilarious watching them getting up,
getting upset about that.
Hey,
don't read their fake news.
Read our fake news.
Read our version of the fucking,
it's all fake fucking news.
Have you ever gotten into a car accident?
Little fender bender and the cop shows up.
Are you a police officer?
Have you ever heard two people tell you the exact same story?
This fucking guy came out of fucking nowhere.
Then you go over the other guy.
What happened?
I came out of fucking nowhere.
I wasn't even looking.
Never happens.
It's all fake news.
It's,
it's all opinions,
right?
For the most part.
Other than,
you know,
if somebody dies,
this guy is fucking dead.
Okay.
You can agree on that.
How he died.
Why died?
Who's,
who's responsible?
Oh,
Jesus Christ belt.
We get it.
Okay.
That's all I'm saying.
That's all.
That's all I'm really saying.
All right,
let's get to,
well,
let's get to the content here.
Um,
the read some,
uh,
some of your letters here.
Alright,
Yoko Ono makes Julian Lennon by letters he wrote to his dad at auction.
All right,
Bill,
is there a worst woman in history?
I hate to be happy.
I know the Beatles days were numbered.
It wasn't just her,
but it didn't help.
Yeah.
But at the end of the day,
John Shows her,
this is what happened.
Something happened between John and his mom and she died,
or she fucking,
I dunno,
she beat him with a wooden spoon.
I forget how the fucking story went.
All right.
But whatever she did or if she died,
it's not her fault.
It left him with the psychological makeup to be susceptible to not trying to
just find a mate.
He also wanted a mom.
Okay.
And all she had to do was make some cookies.
All right.
Make him some cookies on his fucking birthday,
whatever the fuck he wanted.
And then that was it.
This guy was done,
you know,
I think he would eat all if he lived they somewhere in his mid forties he just
would have been like,
all right.
You know what?
What the fuck was that?
Maybe you would've got out.
Maybe.
Maybe he liked it.
I have no idea.
But anyway,
so let's continue.
He said,
then there's the video.
Okay.
Will you call her out for screeching like a maniac during a powerful moment in
history.
Now she won't give her husband's son some paper he gave his dad 20 years
earlier.
This story might be a bit old,
but it doesn't seem to make,
but it doesn't make it any less true.
I watched the clip,
what it is,
what she auctioned off a bunch of his shit
is what it is.
She's not making him pay for it.
She sold it and Julian wants to get it back.
But because Yoko sold it,
um,
he has to buy it back now I in defensive for what I would say is the cash cow
died.
It's not like Yoko could go out and fucking sell,
take a records like a beetle.
So all of a sudden she's gone like,
Holy Fuck,
how am I still going to be able to live in the,
in the Dakota?
So she selling all his shit or maybe her husband died.
She wanted a fucking move on and didn't want to look at all his old shit.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I have no idea.
Um,
but yeah,
I watched a little of that video.
Julian definitely goes hard on our end,
says,
uh,
that you think,
see,
she's extremely manipulative and that,
um,
she knew what the fuck she was doing from day one and I can't remember did
that's actually his mother.
I Dunno.
How is he related that you,
who the fuck knows?
I don't know.
Um,
okay.
Is there a worst woman in history?
Yeah,
there's way worse women,
those women that ran empires and had people killed,
you know,
for whatever fucking reason.
You know,
the,
the story of scar face.
The second one,
the one that Pachino did was based
on a,
a,
you know,
there was the original movie,
but the stories that they used in,
in the,
the second one,
uh,
we're based on a drug dealer of that time who actually was a woman.
So,
I mean,
yeah,
I would say if she was worse,
you know,
having people shot in the fucking street is probably worse than a sell on some
postcards.
But you know,
it's all up to interpretation.
You know,
this is the new me,
the new meditating bill,
the mood more relaxed bill who's undoing the fucking knots of anxiety in his
mind?
I cannot say enough about the fucking meditating.
MMM.
Now that I'm not trying to like get good at it,
I'm just trying to do it.
MMM.
I don't flip out to the level I used to like I think,
you know,
say like 10 is the worst flipping out.
I think I used to walk around,
just walk around on a good day.
I was already at a six compared to how most people are when they're just like
totally chill it out.
So it was a very quick and easy trip up to 10.
Now I feel like I walk around it like a three.
I feel like I've cut it in half.
So now when I flip out,
I kind of just go to six,
which is still totally unacceptable for most social situations.
I still flip out and people look over their shoulders startled,
but not with the level of,
of what the fuck.
You know what I mean?
It reminds you this time I saw
I was on like highway eight or something interstate eight,
I think it was in Arizona and New Mexico.
I know where the fuck was that and this bull,
it's somehow
gotten free.
I mean I was in the middle of fucking nowhere.
I was and there was two cowboys right on horses and these are cowboys.
They're trying to fucking rope a God damn bull,
which I didn't know if he could do,
I don't what the fuck they were doing.
So one of them is trying to distract the bull is the other one is on a horse
that is sneaking up behind it and,
and the horse is sneaking up the way horses sneak up in a fucking cartoon and
this bull at the last second figured it out and he fucking turned around.
You know that look Bruce Willis always does when he looks over his shoulder and
die hard.
It's the same thing except it was a fucking bull.
That's the look that people,
when I would lose my shit prior to meditate,
I would get that look.
Everyone would fucking turn around.
Like,
you know,
the skyscraper was on fire and it was just some fucking balding redhead flipping
out because he couldn't figure out the new operating system on his,
on his smartphone.
Completely unacceptable.
So,
uh,
my temper is,
has really reduced and um,
I'm telling you if I can just not fucking do,
I just made the statement out loud.
It's like my daughter's not going to see me flipping out,
you know,
I'm not saying I want every way.
Hey,
hey,
hey.
Hey.
What?
She's fucking drawn on the wall at some point,
but uh,
she's not going to see me yelling at computers.
It's just not going to happen.
Okay.
And I say it out loud.
When I say it out loud,
that means it happens.
Right?
Okay.
I hope somebody with,
I'm trying,
fuck you guys.
I'm trying.
Anytime I talk about this too of my standup back,
then I'm going to try to fix my temper.
People just start laughing.
They laugh and they point and they make me feel bad.
Um,
all right.
Italy and the European Union pay their Capitol Hill Bill.
I'm just a bill.
Yes.
I'm only a bill and I'm sitting here on Capital Hill and okay.
I'm a political science professor from a school I won't name to keep with your
policy of not naming names.
Uh,
having studied and taught the subject,
it's fair to say I look at what goes on today from a much wider scope.
A wider scope than who?
Me.
I would hope so.
I would hope so wider than me.
Um,
all right.
And that's not something that is only exclusive to receiving a master's in
political science.
Could you pat yourself on the back anymore,
sir?
Did you elbow patch fly off you fucking left arm of your sport coat when you
reach back to that is all,
I love this guy and that's not always something that is only exclusive to
receiving a master's in political science.
Sky should be wearing a scarf with a nice breeze going.
Anyone can read
Solzhenitsyn.
Thank you for fucking sound spelling that for me and others who have honestly
captured an important perspective of history and have a much clearer
understanding of how and why governments and social lights have evolved through
history.
Anyways,
there was one thing that has flown under the radar now that I've gotten my
resume out of the way,
there's one thing has flown under the radar and I think it should scare the shit
out of most European countries.
All right.
Let me start by saying in short that the European Union parentheses,
which in my opinion is run by fascist self interest.
Can I just stop here and say this is the most well-written fucking email I've
ever received on the podcast.
This is incredible.
Um,
let me start by saying it's short to the European Union,
which my opinion is run by fascist with interest,
tried to take control of Italy's army for the sake of your time.
I will spoil the ending.
Italy did not vote to allow the EU to take over that move by the EU.
Alarmed.
Some of my peers who I in 20 plus years of knowing them have not seen them
alarmed by anything in terms of government in the scheme of things,
a banking institution,
openly financing legislation that is trying to gain control of a foreign
countries,
foreign governments.
Military is for the lack of a better term,
really,
really ballsy.
Why do I feel like I missed some information here?
Okay,
so the the European Union tried to take over Italy's army.
Okay.
I see that Italy did not vote to allow the EU to take over.
So when you joined the uh,
okay.
European Union,
they took take over your army,
is that what you're saying?
Okay,
so that move by the EU alarm.
Some of my peers.
What move.
Oh,
trying to take over the,
okay,
but you're jumping back and forth here.
I can't tell what you're talking about.
K to take control of Italy's army case.
So I'm trying to take control of their army.
Yeah.
How would you do that?
Okay.
The idea that,
let me just finish this.
The idea that certain globalist groups are trying to take control of the world
is not an incredible idea among people who are versed in political economics or
conspiracy theorists like myself,
but you know something me,
they just go,
oh,
where do you get your fucking 10 hat on?
And a you,
if you just started saying what the fuck you just said,
you'd probably run into the same problem like you just,
I just said it was the best written email ever and I got lost in it because I'm
too fucking stupid.
I understand what you're talking about,
so it's gotta be hard,
man.
You just got to hang out with people with the fucking elbow patches on their
sport coats,
right?
Yeah.
Anyways,
the idea that certain globalist groups are trying to take control of the world
is not an incredible idea among people who are versed in political economics.
I've heard you talk about stuff like this in the context of a conspiracy and so
other than this possibly possibly being interesting to you,
it's also too,
it's also affirm that you are not out of your mind.
I attached an article if you'd like to read further,
I absolutely would look at this.
How about dad?
Everybody all,
you can't say that I got a 10 add on tin foil hat on.
Whatever the fuck that means.
Half of you say that you don't even know what it means.
You didn't get your tinfoil hat on.
You know,
I don't know what the fuck it means.
Is that,
is that like my antenna?
If I'm doing some sort of pirate radio,
tin foil hat meaning I know what it means.
It means you're out of your fucking mind.
But how did it come about?
A tin foil hat is made from one or more sheets of aluminum foil.
I didn't want the exact or a piece of conventional head gear lined with foil
worn in the belief or hope that it shields the brain from threats such as
electromagnetic fields,
mine control in mind.
Oh,
I see.
Well,
you know,
that's some macgyver shit.
Yeah,
I can go with that.
Right.
Is that a bad thing?
Anyway,
so what were the fuck was it?
MMM,
I've attached.
I,
I wouldn't,
I would actually,
it's a to,
how long is this?
So,
so something I can read,
you know,
I'll read about this and I'll give you my uninformed opinion,
my Moronica opinion on the next podcast.
How about that?
Does that work for you?
Does that grab you?
Um,
all right.
Fat guys turns out to not be fat.
Billy twinkle bows.
This guy told,
I was told by a doctor his whole life that he was fat.
He had this huge frontal thing on going on that turned out to not be a giant
belly,
but 130 pound tumor.
How many people do you know?
We'll start using the tumor defense.
MMM.
I actually looked this fucking thing up.
The guy is fat.
He's very fat.
Even after the fucking tumor.
I mean like he's laying in bed.
Any has,
it's like he has an inner tube of fat going around.
I think like that's what his neck is.
Yeah.
This guy is so fucking fat.
He had 130 pound to Marnie.
Just thought it was part of his love handle.
He is fat.
Um,
I'm glad they got it out of there.
Jeez.
How do you,
how do you get that out of their hundred and 30 pounds?
How the fuck Dee?
I mean,
you've got to take it out in sections
10 pounds at a time.
You need to make 13 fucking incisions,
Jesus Christ,
and just thrown it over your shoulder,
hitting the ground like a fucking bowling
Jesus Christ.
Do you know I knew a guy
dead.
Um,
you know,
everybody's talking about probiotics and they talk about the bacteria in your
gut that know there's bacteria in your gut that's supposed to be there.
They try to scare the shit out of you,
but it's supposed to be there.
It's there for when you die in,
it begins to decomposing process provided you're not full of fucking
preservatives and you just decompose because you not important and you just
become part of the earth again.
But we stick ups ourselves in these fancy fucking boxes because we think we're
too good to be warm food for whatever fucking reason.
But anyways,
um,
alcohol
eats away at the good shit,
the good bacteria that you need while you're alive.
Like you supposed to be balanced and you're supposed to have more of the good
bacteria.
Cause if you have more of the bad bacteria,
you can actually enter your own fucking way.
You're beginning to decompose while you still alive or in a short way you
starting to die.
This is the way this guy explained it to me.
So he started getting a distended belly.
They didn't know what the fuck was going on and he wouldn't go to the doctor.
And then finally you found out,
you know,
somebody said maybe you got to tape worn and that freaked him the fuck out.
They could have been something alive in them.
And he went to the doctor and then they found out that that's what it was.
And uh,
they gave him some medicine and you know,
Eddie Ed to shit it all out.
That's basically what happened.
So,
um,
I dunno,
even then,
I always buy the Greek yogurt and it goes bad.
I,
we think like eight,
I'll slam a couple of scotches and the next morning I have two spoonfuls of
fucking Greek yogurt.
You're going to,
I'll be fine.
I was happy in the life insurance.
They sit down in a nice fucking easy,
you know,
heart rhythm.
That was also meditating when they did it.
You know,
I was being totally present.
I was listening to the sounds of the room.
I slowed my breathing.
I trick those fuckers.
But I also had the Bruins game on in the background so I was trying not to react
to what the fuck was going on cause we left this fucking country goal at the end
of the second period with one second left.
All right.
Crazy Saddam story.
Crazy.
All right.
Hey Bill thought I brighten your day with this crazy account of what went down
in Iraq when Saddam took power,
basically the gathered all government officials in one room,
the current military leader gets brought out on stage.
He clearly,
he's clearly been beaten,
he admits to having committed treason,
but clearly he hasn't.
They then start calling out officials one at a time,
so everyone was scared shitless that they'd be called out and marched out into a
courtyard with the others.
Then after half of them were gone,
the remaining officials were all taken out to the courtyard and told that if
they didn't shoot the traders,
okay.
They and their families would be killed.
That way they all had blood on their hands.
Insane.
Here's the whole account and to thank the u s still did business with sit down
with them after that.
Ha Ha Dude.
As far as I know,
we kind of put that guy in over there,
you know,
it,
and we were cool with the guy until he fucking tried to go around us and start
selling oil to other,
I don't know what the fuck he did.
We,
you know,
okay.
You know what I mean?
Saddam Hussein to the United States.
He was like one of those fucking,
a first round draft choices that,
that's a bus.
He was a bust for us,
you know,
in a very promising college career.
And uh,
you know,
he just,
he just didn't have the passion and actually he was a very passionate guy.
He just wasn't passionate in the wrong,
I don't know who the fuck knows.
I mean it's all evil shit.
That shit is just like,
mmm.
The most base level evil cause then I even trying to hide it,
but I got to tell you when Trump was talking to that fucking guy there,
I'm from Fox News,
Bill O'reilly and Bill O'reilly's give him shit that he was friends with Putnam
putting in or whatever his fucking name was.
And he goes,
the guys that he's a killer to have a fucking standing president go,
well look at this country.
Look [inaudible] we've done my jaw hit the fucking ground,
Mike.
Is he actually going to say this?
You can't say this.
Everybody knows it's true.
But you can't fucking say this now.
We only kill the bad evil the fuck out of here.
It's all fucking evil.
And that goes back to that fake news.
That's why they need to take control of the fake news so they can spin it.
You know what I mean?
The Guy,
he came out of fucking nowhere.
This Saddam Hussein,
where we had a green light,
he came out of fucking nowhere.
Everybody does it.
You know what?
And I fucking do it too.
We're all spinning it.
We're all spinning our own horse shit.
We all think we're fine.
I'm not going to speak for you guys,
but I'm spinning my own bullshit,
right?
This is my favorite video anybody's sent me in a long fucking time.
I'm,
oh,
by the way,
if you want to watch that sit down thing,
uh,
I'll,
I'll post all these videos.
I don't know if I want to watch it.
That stuff.
I Dunno.
I don't like watching shit like that.
MMM.
All right.
109 year old guy smoked cigars and drinks whiskey.
Dear Billy deer farm state bill,
I know you have a life insurance policy tests,
but I thought you might want to see this is 109 year old guy.
Smoked cigars all day.
Not Saying it's great for everyone,
but figured you'd want to hear the title actually marginalized this guy's life.
He's got a great attitude.
He still drives.
He's the oldest living World War II veteran.
You'd really enjoy this.
He talks about having a truck for a long time and they show his old school TV
with the giant dials.
He keeps it all cause it works and he likes it.
Come to Boston.
I fucking love this guy.
He said at one point he smokes 12 cigars a day.
He goes,
I don't inhale.
So inhale,
he goes,
you get in trouble.
The bottom line is,
you know,
whatever's genetics are,
this works for him because I know if I smoked 12 a day,
I have,
first of all,
I couldn't physically fucking do it,
but he,
and it's like a 79 looks like a 78 or 79 Ford pickup truck.
He had an old square TV that's still had the legs on it from like the 70s.
MMM.
The built his house in like 1940.
He still lives there.
He said,
I liked the shit that I have.
It's still works.
So I'm not buying more shit.
It's like,
what I'm trying to do now,
get rid of all this extra shit that I bought
and um,
I've got to tell you,
watching this guy watching his life is the life that I'm slowly moving towards.
It's the life that I want.
MMM.
After running around like a fucking lunatic,
reacting to everything for the first fucking,
you know,
40 something years of my life.
MMM.
You know,
I would like to slow down a little bit is far as being an,
I mean,
look,
I'm still,
I know all you guys are worried.
I got God,
he's going to slow down.
He's not going to be fucking fun.
I'm still going to completely fuck up.
Still going to do dumb shit.
I'm going to be fine,
but I don't have to be walking or I basically walked around,
stuck in fight or flight mode probably from the age of eight till now.
And um,
I dunno,
it's a stupid west starts.
It's funny to observe,
but it really wears on the people around you and eventually it fucking wears you
down.
And it's just like the amount of fucking time that I have wasted arguing with
people where they're not going to change their mind.
I'm not going to change my mind.
I've just,
I,
I've,
uh,
I've done a pass that point my fucking life and it feels fucking great.
I just have to believe that I am.
MMM.
I'm trying to do now when I flip up,
cause I know there's other angry constant listen to this and you listen to this
because I'm an angry country would it probably makes you feel better about
yourself.
MMM.
Which is why I love Bobby Knight.
But you watch Bobby Knight and you're like,
oh my God,
I'm a fucking saint.
Okay
this guy,
now this guy has got a temporary that day.
I'm telling you right now,
if your wife ever gives you shit for having a temper,
it's like you think I got a temper just cut to,
you could be married to that.
And I love Bobby Knight by the way.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
okay.
I just now like,
uh,
I don't know.
I tried to in the moment,
I just tried to fucking like,
this is funny thing that happens.
Like when my daughter,
uh,
you don't need your diaper changed.
It's like,
you know,
you hear him farting and everything.
So you thinking like,
okay,
that's definitely a,
you know,
when you eat without getting into the gross details,
just think you hear the Farc and you think that's the gun sounding the end of
the game.
And then when she get into it,
you realize that wasn't a gun sounding the end of the game or even the end of
the half.
That was the sound of the fucking jets flying over the game,
over the stadium right after the fucking national anthem and the game's about
ready to begin.
MMM.
I left pad save yesterday blocker cheese block,
saved my wall,
took it all on my shirt and all that.
It's just like,
okay,
it's fucking unbelievable.
And whenever that happens,
like a couple of times I went like,
Nia,
she,
why'd you tell me to come in?
She's still going like she could tell.
Okay.
Like does any way for my wife to know whether my daughter is done
going to the bathroom or not.
She's got no fucking idea.
And I apologized,
Eh,
uh,
I just addressed that I was angry and I,
and I did it two more to fucking times and now,
now I got it down.
Now we just say something as I walk up to the changing table at three or four in
the morning.
And I just basically say,
if she's not done,
and you know,
this is not anybody's fault,
this is just part of having a kid don't flip out.
And I,
and I'll see how that works for me tonight.
That's just base.
I just,
uh,
before I just kept it all in my head
and then it becomes like,
it isn't that it's sorta resort real,
but isn't,
I just find when I say it out loud,
then I could fucking address it.
And uh,
so we'll see that.
But,
uh,
I gotta tell you actually fucking really enjoy changing diapers and everything.
We gave my daughter her first bath ever,
right in the kitchen sink,
old school style.
I'm sure we've supposed to have like a fucking hazmat suit team come in and
disinfect the sank and she's supposed to wear a helmet and some scuba gear.
But uh,
that's not how we're bringing her up.
We go and we're going old school,
I've been playing music for and everything,
got this exercise ball and really just kind of puts her to sleep and I just play
music and she just totally chills out.
Okay.
MMM.
The stuff that she's enjoyed so far,
she's,
she likes Herbie Hancock.
I was playing some Billy Cobham some of this shit I just been listening to.
MMM.
What else has she been listed?
Some of the pop stuff she really likes,
I think they just like music in general.
They just kind of like what the,
what is that and a,
I dunno,
it's getting to that point.
She's just starting to be able to look around and eat,
kind of sit there going like,
I think she's actually looking at me right now and then raise you make a guy
contact.
Like,
Hey,
are you fucking looking at me?
Or I was just kind of drift away and look at something else.
I'm like,
all right,
I guess I'm still like an acid trip when she looks at me.
MMM.
But anyways,
we're having a great time and,
uh,
even though I'm not getting any sleep,
um,
it's totally fucking worth it.
And,
uh,
it's,
I'll tell you if you're,
if you're an older dad,
it's not as fucking hard.
They tried to say,
oh my God,
you're old and going to try to do this.
It's like,
yeah,
I'm old and I have a house.
You know,
I'm not some fucking struggling 20 something.
You know what I mean?
Fucking broke kid trying to pay off student loans and then you have a kid,
people in their twenties,
if they complain about having a kid,
I,
yeah,
without a doubt.
I'll listen to that.
But if you're in your thirties and forties,
yeah.
Could go fuck yourself.
All right.
That's it.
Okay.
That's the podcast for a,
for Monday.
Once again,
please check out Nick Depaulo special,
um,
on Seeso this Thursday at 8:00 PM.
I'm challenging,
he's one of the best of his generation.
And one of the best of the last fucking whatever.
Whenever the fuck he started 30 years ago,
uh,
one of my favorites,
and it's a,
it's an honor to be able to plug his special.
All right,
so check it out.
[inaudible] I'll check in on you on Thursday.